In 2014, the qualifying exam for the US physics team had this as question 19.
A helicopter is flying horizontally at constant speed.
A perfectly flexible uniform cable is suspended beneath the helicopter.
Air friction on the cable is not negligible.
So which of the following diagrams best shows the shape of the cable as the helicopter flies through the air to the right?
Is it A, hanging straight down?
B, hanging diagonally to the left?
C, this hook shape, D, the inverted hook shape, or E kind of S-bend.
Now, apparently there's been a certain amount of controversy about the correct answer to this question.
So today, we're going to go up in this helicopter and put this question to rest once and for all.
Let's go.
Here, I'm deploying a battle rope, like you'd see at the gym.
This one is about 15 meters long and it weighs 20 kilograms.
Looks pretty good.
To make sure the rope doesn't come up into the rotors of the helicopter,
Pilot Craig wanted to keep the rope on our right side so he could keep an eye on it.
So we're not going straight forward.
We're actually going diagonally forward and to the left.
But you can clearly see the rope is hanging straight diagonally to the left.
That's a pretty good diagonal, man.